great job especially considering your
incredible challenges this week your
emotional charge this week I just wanted
to say that I am sincerely sorry for
your loss as we all are for sure little
girl alone in my little
when we were looking at the package I
think I saw your your hands were over
Lori's ears I didn't see the package I
honestly I just heard that our producer
came over and was like you probably want
to cover her ears they're in the package
so I tried I also you know I was
breaking down because no one's covering
my ears
how did you possibly focus and get
through that that difficult difficult uh
it was a little rough but you know about
I were able to you know create this
connection as brother and sister through
the past couple weeks and you know at
this point I needed like one of my
brothers I needed family with me at the
moment he was there for me he helped
pick me up so yeah dance it out I told
her that scene you know for a
grandmother to see that she's leaving
that behind I mean that's the proudest
moment I think she was ready to go
because she saw her you know fulfill all
those things that she wanted in her
granddaughter